>> I JUST WANT TO MENTION WE
ARE DOING VERY WELL IN TERMS
OF THE SUMMIT WITH NORTH
KOREA LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING
ALONG VERY WELL.
THERE ARE MEETINGS GOING ON
AS WE SPEAK IN A CERTAIN
LOCATION WHICH I WON'T NAME.
WE ARE LOOKING AT JUNE 12TH
IN SINGAPORE.
THAT HASN'T CHANGED.
>> POSSIBLE SUMMIT I
CERTAINLY PREFER PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S CHOICE OF DIPLOMACY
OVER THREATENING FIRE AND
FEWERY.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THEM
DENUKE RISE.
I'M NOT VERY OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT THAT.
>> SO THE ON AGAIN, OFF
AGAIN MAYBE ON AGAIN NORTH
KOREA SUMMIT WITH THAT,
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL TOM
ROGAN WASHINGTON EXAMINER.
KAREN TUMULTY.
AND MOLLIE HEMINGWAY SENIOR
WRITER AT THE FEDERALIST.
MOLLIE, YOUR THOUGHTS ON
WHERE WE ARE WHETHER OR NOT
THIS SUMMIT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN ON OR AROUND
JUNE 12TH.
>> IT WHOOP CERTAINLY BE
AMAZE GOING WE COULD MAKE
THAT JUNE 12TH MEETING IN
PART BECAUSE WE LEARNED JUST
LAST WEEK WE HAVEN'T HAD A
LOT OF GOOD DISCUSSIONS WITH
NORTH KOREA ABOUT THE TERMS
OF WHAT WOULD BE DISCUSSED
AT A SUMMIT.
AND THERE IS GOOD REASON TO
BE SKEPTICAL ABOUT NORTH
KOREA BECAUSE WE HAVE HAD SO
MANY TIMES MEETING WITH THEM
OF THEM PROMISING NOT TO
PROCEED WITH THEIR NUCLEAR
AM BIGGSS ONLY TO HAVE THEM
BREAK THEIR WORD.
NOW THAT THEY HAVE FINALLY
ACHIEVED THEIR LONG-HELD
GOAL OF DENUCLEARIZATION,
WHAT THEY HOPE TO GET IN
EXCHANGE FOR THEIR CLAIM
THAT THEY WILL DENUCLEARIZE.
>> Mike: WE HEARD SOME
BIPARTISAN SKEPTICISM OR
CONCERN FROM LAWMAKERS.
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN.
>> RIGHT OUT OF THE NORTH
KOREAN PLAYBOOK.
WE ARE IN THE THREE
GENERATIONS OF THAT PLAYBOOK
NOW.
ACT LIKE YOU WANT TO
NEGOTIATE.
THEN COME UP WITH SOME
OUTLANDISH VIEW OF WHAT THAT
NEGOTIATION MEANS AND TRY TO
WIND UP WITH EARLY BENEFITS
TO YOUR SIDE.
AND NOT FOLLOWING THROUGH ON
WHAT HAVE YOU AGREED TO DO.
>> TWICE BEFORE NORTH KOREA
UNDER KIM JONG UN'S FATHER
COMMITTED TO FULL
DENUCLEARIZATION IN SIX
PARTY TALKS IN 2005 AND
2007.
AS SENATOR BLUNT JUST
REFERENCED ONLY THEN TO
CHANGE THEIR TUNE.
>> SO A LOT OF FOLKS FROM
BOTH PARTIES FAVOR TALKING.
THERE IS AT LEAST CAUTION,
RIGHT, KAREN?
>> I THINK, TOO.
THIS GO AROUND, AFTER WE SAW
THE PRESIDENT SORT OF RUN UP
TO THIS ONCE BEFORE, THE WAY
IT'S GOING ABOUT LOOK AS LOT
MORE PROFESSIONAL THAN THE
FIRST TIME.
THE PRESIDENT IS ACTUALLY
LETTING THE PROS, HIS
FOREIGN POLICY TEAM GET IN
THERE AND KIND OF LAY THE
GROUNDWORK.
THERE IS A LOT MORE
THERE IS A LOT MESE
THERE IS A LOT MESSAGED
DISCIPLINE COMING OUT OF
THIS.
NO MORE PREMATURE TALK OF
NOBEL PRIZES THIS TIME.
ONE OTHER THING THAT'S GOING
TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT HERE
IS KIND OF SETTING SOME
REALISTIC EXPECTATIONS.
>> Mike: SURE.
>> FOR THESE TALKS AS
OPPOSED TO THINKING THAT
SOMEHOW, YOU KNOW, BY THE
FORCE OF HIS PERSONALITY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN BRING
ABOUT FULL DENUCLEARIZATION,
YOU KNOW, IN HIS FIRST
MEETING.
>> Mike: IS THE MOST LIKELY
SCENARIO, TOM, THEY COME OUT
OF A MEETING AND SAY WE HAVE
HAD A GOOD DISCUSSION.
WE HAVE MADE SOME STEPS
TOWARDS RESOLVING THIS ISSUE
AND NOW WE ARE GOING TO
WORKING IT?
IS THAT MOST LIKELY.
>> I THINK THAT'S THE IDEAL
SCENARIO FOR THE CHINESE AND
NORTH KOREANS.
SCENARIO FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
AND SEE THIS HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS FRAMING IT
AT LEAST GET SOMETHING
IMMEDIATELY OUT OF THAT
SUMMIT.
WHETHER THAT BE A LIMITED
INSPECTIONS TRIP BY THE IAEA
OR DECLARATION BALLISTIC
MISSILES.
SOMETHING TANGIBLE.
AND I THINK THE GOOD THING
ABOUT THIS, THAT SKEPTICISM
RENDERING THAT AMERICAN
EXPECTATION OF SOMETHING
TANGIBLE MEANS THAT IF YOU
DON'T GET SOMETHING TANGIBLE
THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL GO
BACK TO THIS SORT OF MAXIMUM
PRESSURE APPROACH BECAUSE IT
WILL BE PRETTY CLEAR THAT
THE NORTH KOREANS ARE DOING
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE BEFORE
WHICH IS TO SAY PLAYING
>> Mike: SOUTH KOREAN
PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT THE
MESSAGE HE WAS DELIVERING
OVER THE WEEKEND TO THE
NORTH KOREANS.
TAKE A LISTEN TO.
THIS I EXPLAINED TO NORTH
KOREAN LEADER KIM JONG UN
THE RESULTS OF MY MEETING
WITH U.S. PRESIDENT TRUMP
FROM LAST WEEK AND DELIVERED
THE MESSAGE THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS A STRONG WILL FOR
PUTTING AN EDGED TO HOSTILE
RELATIONS AND HELP ACHIEVE
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY.
PROVIDED CHAIRMAN KIM MAKES
A DECISION FOR COMPLETE
DENUCLEARIZATION AND CARRIES
IT OUT.
>> Mike: SO THERE WAS A LOT
OF SPECULATION THIS PAST
WEEK THAT PRESIDENT MOON WAS
COMING HERE AND WOULD BE
TAKING A MESSAGE WITH HIM.
NOW IT SOUNDS LIKE HE DID
DELIVER A MESSAGE.
RIGHT, TOM?
>> YES.
I THINK THAT'S TRUE.
I ALSO THINK THE CHINESE
HERE WERE TRYING TO TEST THE
WATERS HERE WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP BY TELLING THE NORTH
KOREANS PLAY GAMES.
NOW CONTEXT OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP PLAYING HARD BALL WITH
THEM ON TRADE, THEY WANT
U.S. CONCESSIONS IN THE
SOUTH CHINA SEA AS PART OF
THEIR QUID PRO QUO FOR
PRESSURING PYONGYANG.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS PLAYING
THAT GAME OF
UNPREDICTABILITY.
THIS IS THE ONE ISSUE WHERE
THE TWITTER FEED AND
STRANGENESS OF IT ALL SERVES
AS A POSITIVE INTEREST
BECAUSE IT THROWS FOREIGN
NATIONS WHO HAVE A DIFFERENT
POLITICAL STRUCTURES TO OUR
OWN OFF BALANCE IN TERMS OF
TRUMP MIGHT DO.
MIKE PIKE WE KNOW AN ADVANCE
TEAM WENT TO NORTH KOREA TO
TALK ABOUT THIS SO IT SOUNDS
LIKE THEY ARE HOPEFUL?
>> AGAIN, THEY ARE SENDING
THE PROS IN TO LAY THE
GROUNDWORK.
I THINK PRESIDENT MOON HAS
BEEN IN A LOT OF WAYS THE
MOST INTERESTING PERSON TO
WATCH IN ALL OF THIS.
HE DOES SEEM TO BE KIND OF
UTMOST SKILLFUL AT KIND OF
READING ALL THE INTERESTS
AND SORT OF BRINGING
EVERYBODY ALONG.
>> Mike: MOLLIE, HOW DO YOU
THINK THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS PLAY OUT WITH THIS.
>> IT'S WORTH POINTING OUT
THAT IT WASN'T THAT THE U.S.
WAS NOT EAGER TO MEET OR
THAT THE U.S. WASN'T TRYING
TO MAKE TERMS FOR WHAT THE
SUMMIT WOULD BE BUT THAT
NORTH KOREA WASN'T SHOWING
UP.
>> ALSO THE PRESIDENT SORT
OF GETTING OUT OF HIS OWN
FOREIGN POLICY TEAM.
IN FACT, BY ANNOUNCING THIS
MEETING BEFORE HE EVEN
DISCUSSED WITH HIS OWN
FOREIGN POLICY TEAM WHAT HE
WAS GOING TO DO.
THAT REALLY DID KIND OF
LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF
GROUNDWORK THAT COULD BE
DONE.
>> WHETHER YOU THINK IT'S
LIMITING OR THAT KIND OF
PRESSURE IS ACTUALLY
HELPFUL.
YOU ARE SEEING WITH SOUTH
KOREA PUTTING PRESSURE ON
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE VERY
THEY ARE EERY
THEY ARE EAGY
THEY ARE EAGER TO MOVE
THINGS FORWARD.
IN A LETTER LAST WEEK HE
SAID SOMETHING ABOUT WE WERE
TOLD BY SOUTH KOREA YOU
WANTED TO MEET.
WE WERE TOLD BY SOUTH KOREA
THAT NORTH KOREA WANTED TO
MEET.
KIND OF SUGGESTED THAT MAYBE
THEY WEREN'T CONFIDENT IN
WHAT SOUTH KOREA WAS SAYING.
THERE HAS BEEN SO MUCH THAT
HAS BEEN COMMUNICATED
THROUGH SOUTH KOREA.
AND EVEN TODAY THEY ARE
SHOWING SUCH EAGERNESS.
INTEREST IN GETTING MEETING
GOING.
TRUMP TALKED WITH ABE TODAY.
JAPAN IS VERY INTERESTED IN
GETTING THINGS GOING.
CHINA, I THINK, IS THE
INTERESTING PARTY HERE.
WE WILL NOT GET A DEAL